cosa succede qui mostrato infatti non ci
credo ho visto i benvenuti solida
stories oggi dovremmo scappare dalla
prigione con i mostri sarà un escape
room bellissima con l'incarico di cose
ma iniziamo subito perché ci sono un
sacco di ostacoli proletari tranelli da
superare lasciate un mi piace per vedere
altre skype rubati poter essere un mi
piace entro quattro secondi 4 3 2 1
lasciavano gadget ai tetti di como di
pretesi pop corn e siria montevideo il
critico ecco un prigioniero c'è scritto
maria allora invito d'acqua perché
esistono le frecce da guerra questi sono
stati prigionieri bulloni
questo è un po arrabbiato cosa succede
qui vivremo mostri un prigioniero che si
è trasformato in un mostro sembra che ci
sia un mostro lastre iandolo tipo mostro
che sta spiando da una camera segreta e
scusate ma devo scappare
dormirò liberarvi porte cosa certa
un'altra stanza di sicurezza
maria dice ci siamo occupati delle
guardie ora vai oltre a questi ostacoli
per iniziare la tua fuga buona fortuna e
l'aster imbattuto vestiti sono dopo
l'alba clima ma quindi questa è proprio
una fuga da una prigione di massima
sicurezza
la zero tutti la per i bachi è questo
maria dice stai attenta quando tanti in
questi laser vai nella parte più basta
ok saltiamo qua adoro che pesche per
roma
quanti punti si straccerà vita
distruggerlo io no qualcuno si sconosce
modo fortunatamente no ok vediamo
cos'altro sospetta
io allora o no la porta è chiusa basta
dire questo c'è un mostro di passaggio
mostra bianco uno dei mostri è un alieno
che governa male sono chiusi in prigione
anche loro capiamo brio di un labirinto
io faccio di qua o no tu vai dall'altra
parte non enorme questo labirinto
aspetta che parta da wow
e ora che si fa sta piovendo marine di
se questo posto è orribile partire dal
tasso i tubi più leggeri per non cadere
perché può che non essere se un vostro
dai vieni a prendere il badge qui tanto
importante t forse devo andare qua no
non mi può portare dobbiamo stare
attenti passa da doveva andare saltiamo
sulle scatole anche quelli del potere
bensì nell'acqua ma che cos'è 2 o no è
un mostro tutte le facce ce l'ho fatta
schettino un mostro stranissimo dove sei
e sono caduta non mi dire che sono di
nuovo nel labirinto pure io sono qua c'è
un altro buco ecco perché così siamo
mario rezza
vediamo che cosa dunque entra senza
permesso sarà arrestato
ma noi ce l'abbiamo permesso di questa
prima permesso
pesaro cosa si è rotto o paura che ci
sia uno dei mostri la stessa pesce da
mangiare o no non è il momento di
quest'area mangiare come facciamo finita
qua abbiamo più
io non so dobbiamo farci qualcosa si è
rotto qualcosa
ok vediamo cosa dice maria dice
questionario e di sicurezza
verremo presi quindi continua a scappare
predilesse la porta giusta e continua ad
andare non prenderebbe le prime a zogno
casa sono morto anch'io ho un problema
se prendi la porta sbagliata una delle
porte tifare iniziare dalla vita nella
riportato quindi c'e anche separa opini
non è quella al cenone a quella al
centro pensa sia quella sinistra
vediamo neanche quella
ok e questa è la prima per ora ci sono
altre porte quindi ora lo portò giusta
tra queste tre
[Musica]
non è se proporrà tv che non è centro
come ho fatto non lo so vediamo un
potere sto passare attraverso questa se
non ci credo per puro caso ce l'ho fatta
maria dice stai attenta tra esplode ok
cerchiamo di non toccare neanche se
anche la lava ma costa in questo posto
questa porta è bloccata abbiamo rotto
alcune delle sbarre quindi devi andare
attraverso le sbarre
posso prenderla la possa prendere noi
prende forziste sono nella parte con i
tubi che la ii e vitale si sta
raggiungendo prima la va a questa lava e
super realistica fatto proprio bene
guarda che c'è una kurda attenta primate
maria vito il moto torniamo la porta è
chiusa di nuovo non preoccuparti abbiamo
attaccato alcune forme al ponte è
l'unica opzione per passare bisogna
stare sul ponte si specie di corde la
cascata di lava ma non è nuovo a questi
bruno tagliamo
qua non della zona di sicurezza livello
4 dice o no la sicurezza sta diventando
sempre più difficile questi laser si
muovono non la sai che ti tocchi notiamo
la cosa che fai da te professione
benissimo la per un braccio e ora cosa
ci aspetta ma cos'è meglio che mi sbrigo
casey non so cosa stia succedendo
qualche mostro che mi aspetta roma che
succede qua ma non ti teletrasporti
settore trasporto che mi teletrasporta
non lo so eletto dell'istruzione deve
rimanere immobile ubicato sappiamo che
brume e pigna peccato che abbiamo perso
vitale mari mossi senatur nella prigione
non si cell
testati e piu facile attraversare queste
perché queste particelle ok sappiamo che
abbiamo bisogno di aiuto aiutarmi
prezzate non mi prezzate
e questo adesso penso che devo andare al
contrario ma non è un vezzo cellule tra
bene siamo un tono aiuto spetta poi ti
spingono si aiutami di quanto difficile
di cui si fa devo saltare per rallentare
non mi spiace che adesso quindi diventa
una sera per questo è l'ultimo forze tua
abbiamo quasi usciti ho sentito che
questa è la via d'uscita anche sentito
che la sicurezza sta che stiamo
scappando quindi stanno venendo a
prendervi no quindi scappa com'è stata
la tecnologia che ti farà correre più
veloce dobbiamo scappare la legittima ma
tritatutto nello stato libero aiuto noi
la nava questo tono rime da qualche
parte evitare persero il labirinto non
sono tornati al punto di partenza
infatti questi labirinti sono
difficilissimi anche se farlo
velocemente più divertente al 3 a 3 un
altro teletrasporto ok forse ce
l'abbiamo un po sono ma funziona anche
per noi ci trasportiamo indirettamente
al mare è venuta magica follia ieri
no questo è un nemo me non sembra molto
felice ok che bevete beh direi dopo
questa avventura
prigione di massima sicurezza mela neri
dovrà nuotata figlio che cosa piano fa
un bar
salviamo prima il cibo di razzi il
migliore finalmente del cibo come faceva
parte il cibo come posso ordinare il
cibo povero vitale questi sarebbe
divertito a prenderci bomba dobbiamo
proseguire società deve stare molto
attenta che proviamo via e braille
ora prendiamo bene la mira non è che una
volta uno alla volta a settimana farsela
si nutre mancano pochi spero che questo
nessun altro e dove chiederò cristiano
deve andare dritto a vita
siamo in alto stampa
wow e adesso come si fa ad andare lì ma
il problema del 7 l'ultimo vai
dai da poco che dopo essermi stata
celata un sacco di volte e vitale mi
aiutate a superare signora corriamo con
i corridori gambe e blocca
all'improvviso non ci credo ho visto che
corvino però solo risalire
non va bene piano piano piano o meno
male pensava di dover mai fare accusa la
capo invece sera tv una sorta di
trappola brava mamma mia
questo sì forse sono i cancelli della
prigione forse siamo riusciti a segnare
è così finito vediamo cosa dice maria
la nostra compagnia di viaggio signorina
ma non siamo ancora riusciti a scappare
né vista lire sopra questa corda li
diamo mai i muri della prigione di penso
di sì c'è una capra se cadi da questa
altezza non andrà molto bene e meglio
che salti sugli alberi perché non desse
scendere giù ea capo e la giudico per
controllare che cari ciao
la purezza aiuto ho paura di cadere
ariano chiaro dice ma non posso cadere
ha detto ce l'ho fatta cerchi una
cascata camera questa è riuscita prima
voglio vedere che se questo mi ricordo
che quando dentro o no spero che tu sia
brava ad arrampicare vediamo che si
pensava che prova a saltare da qui da un
muro a muro
no non puoi un filo spinato per
ascoltare
ok vitale mi ha aiutato a superare il
filo spinato perché sono morta 10 mila
volte
saliamo questo mancheranno uscita
non lo so però se devo camminare sui
fili che cos'è quella di matri non mi
devo dire non dover dare dubitiamo i
laser ieri
vediamo cosa dice maria per tenta il
fango è molto profondo ho visto qualcuno
cadere e proprio a dare quindi sono
stabili mobili e fatti
e io che devo cercare di non toccare
permesso un motivo è sorta né sabbie
mobili siamo capiti io ho superato i
mobili o no vero è partita all di
immobili nella storia un potere lupo
hanno liberato i lupi è un lupo un'ala è
sprofondata ei ragazzi allora siccome
queste riforme lunghi illuminati forse
altri dei livelli quindi se questo video
raggiungesse il mila video se faremo la
seconda farne in cui proveremo scappare
da questa prigione di massima sicurezza
così spalleggiate qua sotto e ora vi
lasciamo 4 di salire su cui cliccare per
vedere mentre altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite
buona visione ciao